Dishonored 2 launched last year but that
doesn't mean developer Arkane Studios is
done with it
the stealth action game is set to get a
mission select auction and a bunch of
new difficulty settings in the coming
weeks I'm Matt and this GameSpot news
update is coming to you from the shadows
dishonored twos missions select option
will let players replay a specific
mission with every Power rune and item
they have the first time the difficulty
settings on the other hand while they
come in the form of more than 20
different sliders that allow you to
tinker with very specific aspects such
as the effectiveness of sleep darts and
the number of enemies who will attack
you at once players will also be able to
try their hand at the incredibly
difficult iron mode which features perma
death and lacks manual saves and loads
yes that means you'll have to deal with
the consequences of your actions
update 2 launches on Steam in beta form
on January 18th while the final version
releases for ps4 Xbox one and PC on
January 23rd additional features are set
to be announced leading up to its
release so for that and more news from
the world of video games stay tuned to
game spot
you
[Music]